[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the news gets weirder
the one certainty in the news business
special counsel Robert Muller's
investigation claimed another victim
today someone you have not heard of he
is Dutch attorney
Alex vanderzwaan and he pleaded guilty
to making false statements to federal
agents vanderzwaan worked for the law
firm Skadden Arps from the bigger firms
in this country and partners portfolio
there included work for ukrainian
President Viktor Yanukovych work that
was reportedly arranged by lobbyists
Paul Manafort it appears that Manafort
weaponized a number of American law
firms on behalf of his Ukrainian clients
and Alex vanderzwaan is paying the price
for that tonight so why does any of this
matter exactly none of it has anything
to do with Donald Trump or the 2016
election what turns out as some of us
predicted Muller's investigation has
taken off in unpredictable directions
indictments like the one today exposed
the truth about foreign influence in the
United States other countries do subvert
our democracy but it isn't with vast
election rigging conspiracies those are
fake they're delusional actually the
real threat and it is real is foreign
lobbying and influence buying foreign
interest push us to fight certain Wars
to sign on to certain trade deals to
pass specific laws and too often they
succeed in that that is a clear
perversion of the democracy we were
promised an America governed by
Americans it's also unconstitutional but
foreign influences everywhere hiding in
plain sight virtually everyone in
Washington is implicated in it in some
way that may explain why nobody ever
mentions it and by the way it's a
bipartisan crime Paul Manafort is a
Republican
the Podesta group which helped Manafort
lobby for the Ukrainians was a
democratic firm one of the biggest the
head of the team working on the
Ukrainian accountant Skadden Arps was
Greg Craig he's one of the most famous
Democratic operatives in Washington
Craig was Barack Obama's White House
Counsel before that he was a key
assistant to Bill Clinton for years he's
a huge player in democratic circles is
Greg Craig one of Muller's next targets
we don't know we can't say but what's
obvious is that this investigation is no
longer primarily about the 2006
election assuming it ever was Muller
seems to be closing in on the real
scandal in Washington the one the media
have steadfastly ignored for decades the
real foreign influence scandal and if
that's the case if that's what Muller is
doing
god bless him